each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
um ok so today we are excited to have
Fernando Brando visiting the Clark group
he's a candidate for a research position
in Clark I'm Fernando is from actually
Brazil hails from Brazil and he obtained
his PhD in physics from Imperial College
London currently he's an associate
professor or lecturer at university
college london where you've been for
about a year I think um he's held
positions at ETH Zurich University dad
federal gym menagerie oh shoot i speak
french not spanish or portuguese um and
also university college london imperial
college london and he's interested in
quantum information theory quantum
computation optimization theory
many-body physics computational
complexity and entanglement which is
what we're going to hear about today so
he's going to talk to us about the
complexity of quantum entanglement let's
welcome Fernando thank you thanks so
thanks for the invitation to combine
happy to be here and to interact with
you doing these two days ok so I'm going
to talk about some some work that i did
in collaboration with several people
here are their names and like over 34
papers so the beginning I was not sure
what the audience would be so I put some
like very basic like motivation for
doing quantum computation so on I don't
feel it's necessary here but let me go
really quickly over it right so so you
know the reason why we are doing what
you do is is considering is if we caused
due to different problems right one is
this problem of simulating quantum
mechanical systems right so this is some
plot that I took from a talk by as for
music that many people use it now it
just shows that the time of
supercomputer power from the department
of energy in terms of the disciplines
right and then you can see that like
roughly twenty five percent of these
super computer powers is evolved to
simulate quantum physics right so this
is a very time cost
a simulation problem and you like to to
get a better handle on this problem
right so another another challenge is
that we have cryptography right these
works very well but is all based on
improving hardness assumptions right on
computational hardness of given problems
that we don't know for sure if they are
hard or not write it and of course will
be much better if you can basically on
on really more firm ground right on for
example the laws of physics for exam and
what what quantum information and
quantum computation gives is really a
pathway for solving both problems right
so if you want one day we can build a
quantum computer or like long scale
quantum cryptography systems we can we
can get right much better answers for
these two problems so so the area of
quantum information few you really the
goal is right to try to lay down a
theory for this future for the base
technologies quantum computation called
the cryptography and so on and there's a
lot of like sub areas whether we we
explore here and you work you guys work
on on many of them here so by quantum
communication we understand the ultimate
limits of information transmission right
so we have quantum mechanical systems
and therefore we have to understand how
can store and manipulate and send
information in these systems then at a
known theory we see this quantum
correlations and then going that we
really focus of this talk and some
resourcing in quantum formation science
we understand how to how to use this
resource then quantum error correction
and photo Lawrence is really about this
idea that's this quantum computers
they're actually in a sense digital
computers right we have a mini way of
correcting errors and scaling them up
then in quantum computation like try to
find ways of using quantum computer once
we have one right well try to get
algorithms with exponential speed-up and
quantum of plexi theory just comes from
the idea that once we know that
fundamental limits for computation due
to quantum mechanics we understand what
are the limits for quantum computation
right so what what we cannot do even
with a quantum computer so there's a lot
of work in all these directions right
then and there all very interesting but
I guess a bone
of all this theory is that all this fury
developed it's not only useful for for
right trying to the sea and what we can
do with these new technologies but also
for studying all the problems in other
areas of physics and and in computer
science right then and one of this would
be one of the focus of the talk right so
there's a lot of like emerging
connections of quantum information
theory before the branches of science so
I just put some some like random
examples here right so in condensed
matter there's a lot of stuff going on
between strongly correlated systems and
attainable theory or topological order
and quantum error correction as you know
very well in high energy physics and
general activities there is some very
nice recent connections as well what I
want to focus here is on connections of
our feud quantum information with us
your computer science right and in
particular to optimization okay so
there's been some works on like for
example understand it compressed sensing
better using quantum information ideas
and what I want to focus is to try to
understand this very useful algorithmic
techniques known as SDP hierarchies in
terms of quantum information ideas okay
so where we'll get to that soon okay so
so this talk is really just to give an
example of this connections of quantum
information theory with optimization
theory in particular and and some
definite programming so the problem that
will address from like a pure
mathematical point of view is a very
basic one so it's just like a relation
of quadratic versus by quadratic
optimization so let's start with some
problem which is which completely
elementary right this is just we're
given a matrix ambition matrix for
example d by d and we want to compute
this the maximum over unit vectors of X
transpose conjugate MX all right so this
will be the expression so it's just a
quadratic quadratic optimization problem
in the interest of X and of course this
is a very easy problem right this is
just a max Morgan value of M right so we
just use linear algebra and we can
compute this very efficiently or in the
same very well now let's try to
generalize this problem a little bit
right just just add another another
variable Y so now we have a em again is
a hermitian matrix but it's on a test of
of two vector spaces one did I mention
the other elder mission and I want to we
want to solve the analogous problem but
instead of optimized over any vector we
want to optimize of a product vectors
right so X stands for why we're both are
unit vectors okay so this is just like a
general biquadratic quadratic
optimization problem in x and y let's
all over some homogeneous polynomial
everyone calculate the maximum of this
okay now turns out that this is a much
harder problem now so we don't really
understand very well the complex of this
problem anymore but using some ideas
from quantum information theory we can
both get the best known algorithm that
we know for this problem and the best
hardness result as well and this is what
i want to show you ok so just interrupt
me at any point if you have questions
during the talk all right yes yes if it
was really the difference between the
dobro ok so just just consider X sensor
wire to be a vector in know you can it's
definite vector but here you optimize
over all vectors in this space here you
only optimized of a product vectors
right we also have vector which are not
product right so that's why yeah no
issues yeah it is a teacher yeah that's
right ok so the way that these problems
you appear in the context of what
information is it's trying to solve a
computational problem that's people
study allotting in quantum information
which is problem of detecting
entanglements ok so well I guess I'll
just you all know that so we know a pure
state is use a vector writing in a
d-dimensional complex vector space we
also care about Mick states so these are
just positive semi-definite matrix of
unit traces right so positive
semi-definite unit trace we can always
write as a convex combination of few
states if we want so ok and quantum
measurement is just some POV m element
so let me go skip this now this is the
point so we want to understand when a
quantum states is entangled or not right
so we assume that we have a bipartite
quantum states suppose the pure state
for example so it's just I Satan on the
tensor product of a d-dimensional
l dimensional complex vector space and
other way that we define entanglement is
first to say what's not entangled try so
we say that states is not entangled if
he's at you know it is a tensor product
of two local states I state on a 10 so I
state on file there is it separable and
several means it's not entangled okay so
if you if you do a measurement on a this
is completely independent of the
state-owned be right all of our
information what you do want be now for
mixtapes we have to we also interesting
in understanding when I mixed eight
states when a mixtape quantum state is
entangled so here we are given a density
matrix right is just a set of density
matrices on this vector space and now
again we define what are no entangled
states first they're just convex
combinations of product states okay so
so just take our definition of knowing
tangled states in the queue state case
and we extend to two mid-states by
convex and otherwise if you cannot find
the probability distribution P I and
product States sci-fi I such that we can
write the state in this form then we say
it's anything but it has like quantum
correlations okay yes another all right
yes so i'll get to that nail talk yes
yeah so yeah all right so so now why why
make sense to define an event in this
way right so this comes from considering
this this paradigm that we have in
quantum communication and like
cryptography which is this locc paradigm
so this is the situation where we have
to to Paris Allison Bob and they are far
away right they have like quantum labs
they can they can do whatever operation
allowed by quantum mechanics locally but
they can only communicate classical bits
to each other right so they are very far
away to send quantum particle is very
expensive they can only talk on a
telephone line so now they would like
initially they have no correlations
right they did interact with each other
now they would like to create a quantum
states using this class of operations
local quantum operations and classic
communication this course is like
and it makes the measurements send some
message to Bob classical message Bob
makes out of the measurement sends a
message back to Alice back and forth
exactly Yeah Yeah right so now the the
Hilbert space is given by a tensor
product of dental space of L stands for
vector space robot now several states
are exactly these states which we can
create by this class of operations right
so they can just share like you know
some some coin given by the probability
distribution P I they just sample from
this coin if they get outcome I Ellis
prepares the steps I I locally and Bob
prepares the State Fire I locally okay
so it's clear that any states of this
form can be created by by just like
classical coordination and turns out
that any state that cannot be written
this form requires some kind of quantum
interaction right so therefore there
must be some quantum correlations there
so to entangle States is just states
that cannot be created by locc they have
this no classical correlations okay so
now we get this computational problem
that's that i would like to twist out in
this talk and the computational problems
is the following we are given a density
matrix right it's just this PSD positive
semi definite matrix of unity trace and
we want to know if it's ain't enghadr
not right if it corresponds to entangled
States or to a separable state so now
it's useful to allow some error in the
answer right some accuracy for the
problem so this we use this week
membership formulation so it's easy to
see that the set of separable states is
a convex set right is to set over here G
is the set of all density matrices and
now this week membership problem is the
following so it's a decision problem and
we are given a state royalty and you
wanted at their mind if it's separable
if it's inside here the set or if it's
absolutely from several and if it's
outside here so it's really there is no
separate state close by and of course we
we have to use some norm to quantify
writing this epsilon and we'll get to
that soon ok so it's just some some
version of of deciding an angle where we
don't care what happens here one in this
boundary all right you know what we
understand is how efficient we can x
right solve this problem there's also
the dual problem right is the
optimization problem is a week
membership problem so there is the
optimization version of the problem and
this is really just when optimized over
elements in this convex sets right which
is a set of separable states and here
you can see that this function that I
mentioned before our peers right so this
eighth step is called like the support
function at this point M of the steps of
separable states the definitions use the
maximum over separable states off of
this linear function trace M Sigma right
m is just whatever matrix right it's a
fixed matrix on this bipartite vector
space and then right of course these are
separable states we know they're convex
combination of product states and we are
take the maximal over convex sets so the
optimal solution is in the extrema
points which are just product states so
we have exactly the same biquadratic the
optimization problem okay so the problem
of deciding entanglement is tightly
connected to this by quadratic
optimization problem one is like the dew
of God if a good algorithm for one you
can convert it to a good operation for
the other but I'll get to that morally
yes is somehow interpreted as a distance
between M&C the trace lot is just a
trace of the matrix even buy the product
of the children right way yeah so we're
works amazing that was though so this
problem is just that you have this
convex set and you wanna and you just
want to maximize a linear function over
elements of the sets okay this is the
definition of this problem now that
there are well known results in in like
a convex optimization which says that if
you can solve this problem you can solve
the week membership problem so and vice
versa so the ability of so v1 gives you
the bills of solving the odd right so
when we study spot we can study this in
place of its end and vice versa what
extent is that notion of being separable
or not stable under a discretization of
our numbers so if i work instead of with
reals i work with flow
right yeah it's a it's a good question
again it could make or break the fact
that it's so yeah so there might be
there might be some decomposition terms
of product States which you cannot write
if you only have right so like some pics
they're cursing in their element right
of your matrix right so but that's why
we allow for this error but well if this
error then is fine they will take care
of all these numerical issues yes it's
it's here yeah don't worry about this
worry about if I may get some very small
can i still decide oh no I know if
exercised me I don't know like
explanation is more win the dilation or
something right 10 to the minus 5 yeah
so I don't know for this so you know you
just it's a good question i don't know
like given the fix error what deckers
you need from the from all the limits of
the matrix such that doesn't make a
difference right so actually don't have
to think about the wheels yeah that's
true yeah if i also need to do with the
condition of you right yeah but so so
what we have in mind here is just that
with how elliptical is that said it's
really soon yeah yeah so here will be
most interesting in constant epsilon
okay and then we just yeah okay take out
the didn't work where is much smaller
than that so in the relevance for this
right is just what i mentioned before
entanglement is this resourcing in
quantum information science like for
cryptography or quantum communication so
on so so usually know when someone gives
up some experiment for doing something
useful the first test it should do is
just to talk there is entertainment or
not there right then they should
characterize it further but this is this
do like in a sense of minimum
requirement so so because of these are
people who study this problem like in
the past 15 years since since like the
beginning of quantum information and and
I what I want to show you some results
on this so but now before I get to the
results there is this norm here right so
there is how we quantify the distance
into density matrices right there are
several ways of doing that and it turns
out that this is important first right
how we quantify this so so let me just
show you some options so this is how we
quantify the distance in the week
membership I a nice geometric way but
not the most operational one is using
Hubert Schmidt nog this is just the
ecclesia norm for you know if it treats
the quantum state is a vector right so
this is this is norm it's just trace x
dagor x to the one-half a more
operational motivated version is what we
call this trace norm this is the
mathematical definition but it's used
for one because if you look to the trace
norm of the difference of two quantum
states then if this is equal to two
times the maximum over measurements
quantum measurements of trace em
romancing right so this is just potm
element and we look at trace em
romancing so really this tells us the
cmas ability of throwing sigma if this
is a small doesn't matter what
experiment you do on raw or not see one
day we have similar outcomes okay so for
all practical purposes if there is no
mrs. molded two estates they are the
same now from thinking about this decent
lab paradigm of having a listen Bob and
they can only pray it locally there is
another operation motivated normally we
can think of and this you turn out to be
very useful here which is recalled the
locc norm okay so this is the norm which
tells the distinguish abilities of two
quantum states and the only loco
operations in class communication right
so we have a restriction on the kind of
operation of measurements that we can
implement and this just represents this
restriction so I was a particular simple
set of LCC which is what you can say
something about which is called one-way
LCC this is very simple alias makes a
measurement get some outcome communicate
the outcome to Bob and then Bob makes
another measurement conditional this
outcome and then they can implement some
measurements in this way so this
definition is exactly like the trace
norm but M is not any measurement is
just a measurement that you can
implement by one-way locc and because
there is like only forward communication
from Alice to Bob actually there is a
nice characterization but you won't need
it so don't don't worry about this is
just a mathematic way of writing but
it's just like a sum of
positive operators here on else involved
with so normalization this does Amell I
this this one reflects the fact that we
only allow communication classical
communication from Alice to Bob and all
the other we're not like back and forth
we could we could also causes of this
norm where there's as many rounds of
communication as we want but there is
also be more about this norm difference
here then here this will be more
complicated so then you would have to
have a recursive definition like you
define 41 and 42 would be like this one
and there's a lotta measurement here
with uh with yeah it gets guess I this
gets extremely messy like the LCC for
example it has just been put this off
even a course of sex okay so this is the
second complicates things a lot
thank you alright so you see and around
and all the way to infinity yes we able
to approximate all the measurements era
not so they are the bathroom there are
definite measures that can only be done
no local rate even like you many rolls
of communication for example measuring
like a in a basis of in a bell basis
right so you measure like in the base of
maximally entangled states this cannot
be done by locc not even approximated by
AC analysis all right so the question is
tell whether roy is entangled right
there's this Rick membership problem as
I said there is a lot of fury behind it
there's lights concepts of PPG states
and tangled witnesses they're all
developed so try to solve this problem
but once you turn this into worst case
analysis for our whims they are not very
interesting so they only give like
pretty bad algorithm so I'll denote the
local dimensions of a buy this and of P
by this so they give like roughly
exponential time vibrations on OK in the
local dimensions
ah no so but yeah so we don't we don't
send the average case of Serapis we
don't have much results yeah but we do
we do know is very costly even on prexy
okay so it's not that there's some
pathological cases and on and more for
most cases very easy we do know that
usually takes it's very hard to tell
whether I say the same thing go download
okay and the same for 8 sep okay so we
don't know we have this kind of we had
this kind of bound and this is no better
than just doing an exhaustive search
alright so we also have some we also
understand why this product is hard
right it turns out it's a it's a
computational hard problem for some
parameters of the error okay so this
does for more result by graphics and
then many people work on that you can
prove that the problem is np-hard when
the error is pretty small it's like
polynomial polynomial is more in their
local dimensions and then this works for
any norm you want either one norm which
is stronger or two norm it so it's it's
always np-hard even like if you care
about this is for every small error
right even for constant error there was
a harmless result is more difficult to
states but let me try so this just says
that if you look at this time complexity
right so it's exponential some constants
log of a log of P up to something small
Corrections it not this is like sub
explanation right so pious pulling all
the time so it shows that under some up
assumption that will tell you there is
no algorithm of this complex okay even
when the error is constant it's like no
0.01 and this for any any such number is
bigger than 0 okay I mean very specific
because this would be important function
in the following so it seems that there
is this limits of of getting an
algorithm of like faster than
explanation log dimension of a log
dimension of P and the hypothesis is
stronger than NP hardness is what we
call this exponential time hypothesis
which says that such freesat cannot be
solving in like sub exponential time
okay in time like Fess then 2 to the N
roughly okay so under this assumption we
have even this very strong car kind of
like in approximate bees okay
so sets an extra yeah it's a lot of
things he did so that's a much fish for
this water strong analysis it so i
posses but as far as we know it
correctly it's alright passable but I
mean a lot of people would they stop
short of declaring the increase the
semester right so okay so you know you
can relax this a little bit but the
minimum that you need to have any
non-trivial here is that you cannot
solve sat in time less than two today
square root of n so you need something
stronger than NP hardness but doesn't
have to go all the way after explanation
it's just to get this nice answer okay
all right so this is what was known
write algorithms in the hardness results
then now let me tell you what what we
got a few years ago and was the
beginning of off i'll tell you next is
that if you look in terms of algorithms
actually you also you can get the same
scaling ready this simply exponent so no
it's not a press for our rhythm but
shows that it's much easier than this NP
hardness resort might suggest at first
sight right so there is a like we call a
posi polynomial time algorithms so it is
polynomial both in the dimension of of a
and dimension of be so it's been in the
air so this only Goodwin arrow is is
like constant or something right and
this is both for the euclidean norm or
for the one-way locc nor okay so now as
I said this to norm is good from some
geometric point of view this one way
else the norm is more natural from
operational point of view right and then
what what's intriguing is that is this
this bound right ok so I'm saying here
so one corollary is that you know in too
long the problem cannot be np-hard when
the arrow is is somewhat large right
like poly log because if it were we
could solve sat in sub exponential time
right so assuming that we cannot be sure
that there is a change in complexity
from very small error to kind of arrow
which is a little bit bigger Wright's 02
till you have to contrast with this one
another another thing to mention is that
well first the same thing is true for
the optimization version of the problem
except
but now we we cannot do for any am we
have to do for special m and roughly and
based in 4m which is one way locc we
write for this kind of measurement of
matrices we have this kind of valuation
as well and now you can compare with
this right so from this result by these
guys right that there is no such an
algorithm with this running time now the
thing is that in their result they can
only prove hardness for a slightly
bigger class let's go separable is
almost the same as one way Alice you see
but the normalization is different ok so
we have like almost like we have like
very suggestive algorithms versus
hardness results the function seems to
match but the norms are wrong ok so and
this is one of the open questions like
to solve in the end so it really appears
there is some suggestive evidence that
this might be the right complexity for
for the separability problem but we
don't know yet right so we have
evidences and its really to put them to
get this open product all right so how
what is this operation okay so it turns
out this our food is not new is actually
just based on some very useful wait when
did I start sigh I lost track of time
yes sir ok thanks so it turns out that
what we do is just reapply a well known
algorithm technique to this problem ok
we just find a way to analyze it better
and this is what is called this sum of
square hierarchy ok SOS here here I also
known as last year here a key ok so this
problem except right let's focus on this
now which it's easier to analyze we just
maximize over unit vectors and this
point in this classic function right so
by quadratic function in the elements so
this is just a polynomial optimization
problem under the hypersphere and the
hypersphere are just polynomial
constraints again right this is just
like some over X i squared equals 1 so
whenever we have a pull-up organization
of a polynomial function or polynomial
constraints we can use this year cadets
call SES as here key then I will show
you the next slide more details but
basically this hierarchy that is also
called La Serre was also introduced by
perilla independently what gives is the
same a sequence of seven definite
programs right and this seems same day
field
as we can solve efficiently in the
dimension of the matrices that
approximates increasingly well
dysfunction this number hey ty research
between two the two subspaces no it's
more elaborate yeah oh yes i'll show you
more like consider are you know long
long step versions in opposition oh i
see ya know this yeah i think this
appeals yeah but uh is it more like
Doris Doris here instead of a question
is that a product of of too hyper stairs
but you're right sure yeah yeah it's
just yeah right sorry frost yet we had
you have to hyper skiers in it here
there wasn't people by in dormant here
all they came up with a cubist it's just
this 1i yes yes we'll get good points
yet so so they has two properties are
useful first there is like a que an
integer which permit rises the level of
the hierarchy that you are for each K
this is TP and the size of the stp is
polynomial the dimension of em and
exponential in NK on the levels ok and
we know that when K goes in fields you
really converge the right solution for
every m so if we if you're willing to
wait long enough we can always get as
good approximation as we want so this is
a nice hair key because know there are
all all different kinds of stp herrick
is like or also finial programming
hierarchy is like Sheryl Lee Adams and
and low battery free and so on that's
the question that will address here and
this is like we don't we know for a few
problems for example this theorem that I
show will come about trying proving that
this converge test like test in log n
steps login levels bit well yeah we'll
get to that so this is he a kadai is
very interesting because first is a
stronger ICP hierarchy that we know so
you know if we want to try to solve a
problem you should use it try to use it
and see what it gives a lot of
connections with interesting things like
this there is sum of square proof system
no it's a way of like autumn of ultimate
sizing proof I don't know much about it
but it's tightly connected it's quite a
real job right geometry
and two and as you see just now to DC
but 17th problem okay so let me just
show you very briefly what is what is he
our key does in a very simple case so
the problem is the fall is suppose you
have a polynomial f of X over the rules
and we just want to decide whether this
polynomial is positive okay so its
bigger than 0 for all points now there
is a there's a particular class of
polynomials for which they are always
positive by right by construction is
that right these are the sum of squares
right so we say that Apollo is the sum
of square if we can write it as a sum of
square of other polynomials right of
course this is always positive right
moreover actually if i give you f and
you don't want to check if it's positive
well you just want to check if it's the
sum of squares this is an sdp okay so
how is that CP well so you will give an
f of X of degree G and it's a sum of
square if and only if there is some PSD
matrix Q such that we can write F in
this form so we just write a vector
Zeb's which is odd they're all all the
monomials okay from the grid 0 after the
D over 2 and then we just like say these
polynomials are the same and the same
means that we just look at all the
coefficients of this one and equate with
the coefficients of this one and now if
this is sum of squares you can prove
that Q most ppsc lizard presentation so
you can just look for a representation
of this form with a PSD q yeah right so
so to check if Polumbus SOS that's
actually very efficient right in right
of course it grows with a degree of
explanation of the degree of the
polynomial but for 46 degrees it's very
good this shouldn't be here now it
should be okay so what's this hierarchy
this hike is to try to use these
arguments to solve this original problem
okay it turns out that there is no good
prioritization for this problem actually
to compute this problem in general it's
NP hunt but there is a way of
approximating solution of this problem
using this kind of argument and this is
exactly this SOS here
ok so the level K of the hair key is the
following for this particular instance
you just take f of X you multiply by
this polynomial which is of course
positive and you check if this product
is sum of squares or not ok this is SVP
of size M to the order K right so far no
for every K you can solve this SCP and
see what you get now it turns out that
this completes when K ghosting field so
turns out that the polynomials positive
if and only if there exists a cake for
which this is sum of squares ok in other
words every policy polynomial can be
written as a as a rational function of
two SOS Polly notice this was a problem
the 17th filled with a huge problem
proposed by hubris a long time ago and
solve by arching in 25 okay so so this
is like a goes a long way in mathematics
but the innovation of plus Empire will
was too what's observe they can solve
this by stp ok so this gives this
hierarchy of st p's all right very good
so so of course we can apply this well
problem right so we have an optimization
problem it is turn into a decision
problem so the maximum of this function
is equal to the minimum real number such
that this is a positive role model right
it seems to see you just put these on
the other side you / this tool to be
unit vectors and you get it so now we
just have to check that this polynomial
is is positive and of course we can
apply this here this is the K level of
the hierarchy ok so you have something
of this form alright so so definitely
you you can use that but now what I want
to do is look at this quantum angle to
the problem ok so what I want to do is
not consider this derivation of the hair
key right but actually show you how we
can think about the Sierra key in the
quantum way ok using using like quantum
states and and mooch apartheid states
and so on and this will give a listen my
view a more natural way of thinking
about the Sierra key and then once we
have this view of the hierarchy we can
prove the theorem which is basically
saying that the hair key converges
faster they then then
like next money for that yes you see
it's gonna be hard is it be not to be
envied this here yes well you know I
believe pete is different from MP right
so this particular problem is not
believed to be oh yeah yeah indeed
because it's so in general yes because
you can prove that to the termite so you
know to solve this problem for every
polynomial it's NP hard in the degree of
the polynomial run out in the number of
variables well your guess this case
really predictable or exactly so if you
wanna solve this problem in general and
in the worst case here indeed you have
to go to K which is linear in the number
of variables which gives explanation
time solutions right for each if they
will be such a thing for each end there
is such a cake but the key might be very
big in it but now here we we are
interesting the special polynomial right
so there is hope that you can do
something there but which is here so so
career started looking at these these
polynomials yes as a way of finding the
open elections right yeah it's a control
theory problem right there I don't know
that in this very oh this is sort of the
converse problem in a way which is ok so
what functions can reach with us on
ovals right I mean the objective is a
pun intended is to come up with
something that actually forces the state
down in the usual way up enough
stability way yep and so the question is
how general is that for how big I the
history this to be interesting ya know
they thought yeah I'm some reason Boston
Deaconess after you know how this cable
god it's true but you know it's actually
much before re Louisville right so like
a short not short from quantum algorithm
but the other shot from optimization
they also what so see this hierarchy a
long time ago and this came from this
several different communities they all
came to the same right to the same I
wish all right so so now i wanna know
fight is quantum way of looking at this
year key ok and this quantum way we will
come about considering a very
interesting feature of quantum
correlations of entanglement which is
the fact that this this they are not
shareable
okay so let me explain what share boy is
so this is say that classic correlations
are shareable what I mean well supposed
to have a separate would state I set up
this form so this is a state between
Alice and Bob now right now it turns out
that we can find a bigger states between
Alice and many bobs such that all the
correlations between Alice and each one
of the bugs are the same ok so how we
construct this state well that's the
state right so we just take the same
probability bution the same state on
ellis and we take K copies of this date
on board right so this is a state for
which all the marginals of a and each
one of the piece is the same and is the
original one right so in this sense
these correlations between Alice and Bob
they can be freely shared right with an
arbitrary number of pops so this is the
motivation for making this definition
which is that I States the quantum state
royalty is K extendable if we can find a
bigger steps of Ellis and kebabs such
that for all J from 1 to k if you take
this state we take a partial trace over
all the Bob's except the jf one we
recover the original state right so I
set this KX table if there is a state of
this form for which all these reductions
a and B 3 or a and before they are all
equal to the original states ok so the
correlation between Alice and Bob can be
shared to kebabs in this case now the
interesting thing is that integrant is
is monogamous in a sense right so this
is called bottom you're in 10 minutes we
talk a lot about in quantum cryptography
for example but here really just use
another characterization of entangled
states right so it turns out that a
state is separable if and only if this
states is K extendable for ok ok so if
it's if it's several we know it's
extendable for ok I just show you how to
construct the extension but it turns out
that this is necessary sufficient for
for being entangled if it's entangled
for some K has to fail ok so that you
cannot like share these correlations
arbitrary so this gives our way of
setting up an algorithm for the problem
right so we are interesting
characterizing this set the set of
infinitely extendable states and what we
do we can just well come up with a
hierarchy right we say ok so let's test
if they
it's two extendable if it's not we know
it sent a good if it is then we test if
it's free extendable if it's not too
noisy entangled if it is free extreme we
have to go to forex tandem and so on
right so we have the sequence of tests
and to see how well this performs as
like computationally we have to ask
these two questions right so first how
close does several states Roy be is if
there is a que extension right we know
if for every K there is a key extension
several but is there some approximate
version this is one problem the second
problem is how long does it take to
check if a que extension exists or not
but sighs what the hell is wrong yes
that's right Paul that's right yeah
that's true any fear and it felt like no
maximum 10 books someone then then your
your mom's only then all right so now
what's this that matter a mission this
was you know this was discover 13 years
ago by Dorothy para Lou that was one of
the guys introduced the hair key and
Ally airy they just saw well this
problem this is for the 8 sep version
right so where you have the week
membership as well this problem of
computing this is equivalent to of
course you can write the sum of square
here a key for this problem but is this
is also equivalent just to optimization
over K extendable states ok so so like
when you go to high extensions what
really are doing is to go to higher
levels of Las a hierarchy plus some
other tests this call PBG tests but
these won't play a role in in what you
follow but so what's a way of writing
this sdp where we just maximize trace em
is the input of the problem / / matrices
by such that there exists a big PSD
matrix of units trace for which all the
reductions between a and b j equals 2pi
ok so basically i just optimize the
linear functional over the set of k
extendable states now we add something
more that's not only their k extendable
but if you take the posture transpose
over some set of this
this is your validation matrix ok don't
worry about this constraint is this is
just recover lasya but we don't know how
to use this this is another open
question so basically I think that last
set is really just instead of optimizing
for several states over this my
quadratic optimization problem you relax
over some set of you know bigger quantum
states which gives a proxy to several
states ok so this is what what's
happening here I remember back then many
people try to show that this actually
finite in the sense that given the state
there will always be a k that's true and
it should unknown but is it now solve
that I already steal your thunder but is
it is this well it's study the truth is
also even before they did this because
there are some works that are mentioned
on my particle physics giving the entity
but right when they were walking on that
a tunnel what what they knew for each
for each a tango said you can find a
cave for leeches off but this game aight
be of course very big so we are all
right so this solve this question right
so how long does it take to check if a
que extension exists well it takes time
you know local dimension to the power of
K roughly right because we have a STP
for it should I mean testing with it
with an entanglement witnesses different
question it's it's very close this like
you know cause I mean isn't already high
hydroplane that's right but once I right
so to this basically optimization over
the separating hyperplane right so if
you solve the week membership version of
this problem if you get an infeasible
solution many nights insane tangled but
then if you go to the duel this will
give the hyperplane which is the
entangled witness ok
alright so now the question really is
how close we are from separable rights
if we if i say this k extendable right
so so how fast this hierarchy works and
there's a lot of work like starting or
I'll put the reference here but no
starting from paper by like a high note
Vanna in 1888 i think is to study these
bonds that we call the phonetic theorems
okay that they're useful for several
things well now here just I don't want
explain what the i just want to show
this kind of bound that was not before
it's known that when k grows the set of
k extendable states rights if Rho is the
K extendable state it gets closer and
closer to several but the bound wasn't
so useful for our if mix of our iffens
because it was you know it was very as a
quadratic as the square of the local
dimension so if you look at the K that
you need case the level of the hierarchy
right to get a good approximation this K
has to be proposed to the dimension and
because the st p's explanation k these
only give exponential time algorithms
right so this shows that the heck is
complete but doesn't give something in
terms of algorithms and actually this
you know it turns out they cannot
improve on that there are examples which
saturate I will saturate inequality so
this dimension if you on one arm which
is nice not that I mentioned if you
really want in one arm there's not much
you can do here so now this theorem that
I mentioned before comes from a
information theory result from right
from like resulting quantum information
theory which witch is which is the
following that if I state is K
extendable but now we don't care about
trace not but we allow one way else is
your norm or two norm they don't have an
explanation improvement in the
independence of the definity right
doesn't go with dimension local
dimension but it goes if log of local
donation okay and once we put this into
the problem we get exactly this running
time dynamic peso so this is the main
result we have behind this initial
theorem that that I show you is really
that how well k extendable states
approximate separable states goes with
with the number of qubits of the states
and not with the dimension if you use
this to norms if you use one norm is
much worse right so there
is huge difference between the norms
they use and if you want to stop being
more efficient you have to use this this
week on orbs all right so all this is
just I guess right so if you use this
number of rounds of SOS right we know
that we can solve put in here we know we
can solve the problem with error epsilon
and the size of the SDP is just the size
of the extension and the size of the
extension the dimension of text nation
is dimension of a times I mention of B
to the power of K because they State has
won a parts and kb parts right so
putting the numbers we get exactly this
running time all right so I guess let me
see I'm running out of time and I want
to mention some some applications of
this result to to purely classical
problems which was the question map
asked so I had a sketch of the proof the
proof basically is to use quantum
information theory ideas okay so like
you know use mutant information and you
use chain rules and so on and then but I
always keep that because I don't have
much time so so this was just to show
how you can prove it using some quote
information ideas and then let me get to
this classical problems then okay to
finish the talk so now it turns out that
this H step of course is useful for for
serviceability which is this probably
care about in quantum but it's also
equivalent to a lot of other problems
that people consider elsewhere and I
just want want to mention these
connections and and what we can learn
about these problems right so so what I
just show you is that this last year
hierarchy is sum of square hierarchy
there's a way to think about it in
quantum terms right you can fill in
terms of quantum states and extensions
and right and I didn't show you but the
once we have this way we can use quantum
information tools to bound how fast it
works right so now is just make sure to
apply these bounds that we have to to
other problems right to classical
optimization problems right in see what
it is so this is what I want to show you
so we don't have like a killer result
yet but we have some I think some
suggestive evidence that something
useful might come out of it and and i
want to show you know
so there are several like equivalents
which are pretty easy to show and won't
be the focus like you know one thing is
equivalent to compute the objective
normal tensors by the objective norm is
just this generalization of of the
maximum eigen value of singular value
for other problems in quality
information can connect them to like
compute the minimum output entropy of a
quantum channel in infinity norm atlas
is equivalent to accept or computing the
optimum acceptance probability of
quantum early Earth approves with to
prove us to independent provers is the
same as 8 sep there's a lot of other
problems in quantum information that are
equivalent not a problem that I want to
focus is this problem of computing the
224 norm of a project or of a matrix in
general so this is just some hyper
contractive norm right so the definition
is that we maximize ave unit vectors the
four norm of B times X ok over over X of
unit vector a now it turns out that that
you can relate these two things so you
can prove that if these any matrix
actually doesn't have to be a project
the two to four norm of this matrix
equals 28 step 44 IM of this form ok so
k is just the computational basis and
this is what you get so if you if you
can compute H step in general we can
compute this form for all for all tees
okay so so why is that well it's very
simple so let me just go really quick if
you have a matrix a right so we all go
through the 224 number of a i was
calling p before so this is the
computational basis whatever you want
and here is vectors right so you can
always write a in this form you can
always find the vectors a of I for which
kept away can be written in this form
now there is it the right direction
right okay so so now you know of course
by this identity which is very easy to
verify you see that if you can compute H
sep you can compute 224 norm as well
right just because this 224 norm is a
particular case of 8 sep right away and
this is just a myth now actually all the
way is also true which is the more
interesting direction if you can compute
or least like if you can approximate
24 norm then you can approximate h0 ok
so turns out that they have similar
complexities to problems and this use
some quantum argument as well that's I
would just keep if you want you can ask
me later so then use some ideas from
quad information to prove that so now
why these two to four always interesting
well for one thing because you know this
is a hyper contractive north right so
these are peers like you know a Markov
chain if you want to prove convergence
time of the Markov chain one a bound is
224 norm but but more really because it
connects to two other problems that I
just staple there which are which are
like you know very important problems in
current research in combinatorial
optimization which are problems that we
don't understand the complexity and we
don't understand what we can do in terms
of algorithms but they will I to
understand and maybe this one actually
tells us something so let me just tell
you what the problems are if you don't
know one is related to this unique games
conjecture ok so before tell you what
the conjecture let me tell you what the
unique game problem is this is the
problem is the following oh it is the
conjecture array ok so this tells you
deaths suppose you have a system of
equations of this form just twit two
variables / equation X I plus x j equals
C mod K ok what these are like two
integers so it is solving assists linear
system of equations with two variables
over some finite field now this
conjecture tells us that this is a very
hard problem actually even to estimate
it tells us that it's NP hard to tell
whether more than 1 minus epsilon
fraction of the constraints are
satisfied whoa meaning there is a there
is a assignment for the eggs which
satisfies 1 minus epsilon fraction of
this in of these equations or if you
cannot satisfy Eve even an epsilon
fraction of them okay so your promise
that either almost all of them a size 50
or almost none of them a size 5 anyone
understand anyone decide which is the
case and the connections that this is an
np-hard problem okay so this is just a
problem you of course you can make this
congestion now yes you need because the
constraints these are a constraint set
sexual problem of every two and is
unique in the sense that's given one
assignment for this variable there is a
unique assignment for the other variable
which size five
aw strain and vice versa right so if you
choose X I say equals 1 there is only
one choice for XJ that would satisfy
this constraint and vice versa is only
solution is like it is a unique is a
unique choice for one of the variables
in a constraint given the choice of the
other one so is it sorry unique strategy
right okay okay see in case of just part
of the problem right with your feeds
from the behaviors are really key for
for a contract is that for any constant
C and MK decision yeah ah doesn't
anything to do with the number of number
of knows photo give you so you don't
know any of X it's right that's the you
have any exes and variables and you
don't know what they are okay right any
what you had some serve those right
right yeah yeah the problem skin scales
with M the number of variables X 800 if
K is very small yeah i mean i think this
yep behave like like set like ASAP in
that right if you have too many yet
constraints then there's no solution if
you don't know very minute oh sure shot
yet right then it's easy and it's only
for critical k right k is some function
event to make this hard i think it's the
point so what is a super is not in terms
of guessing maybe I was in terms of K
but in terms of how many how many
qualities you have rises in you know you
have like you have n variables and you
have other n like qualities right
constraints yes and then of course there
is some ratio for which is the hardest
yep yeah alright so now white people
care about this pro right why this is
the important problem well for many
reasons but one of the reasons is that
how a vendre proof that if the unique
games conjecture is true then if you
look at the second level of this SOS
hierarchy okay this is the best possible
algorithm gives the best possible proxim
a shin for any constraint satisfaction
problem ok so this constraint
satisfaction problem is it is a huge
class of combinatorial possession
if you can prove that we really
understand everything you can do in
terms of algorithms here but we just use
last year second level we get the best
approximation possible and try to get an
approximation better than that it's NP
hard okay so it really met a problem for
which if you want to sell it well we can
understand a lot of other problems and
you can see this as just a major barrier
in our current knowledge of algorithms
right for this problems now this is not
really a conjecture that everyone knows
is true in fact like it's really could
go either way okay it's really like
where our knowledge goes and one of the
ways to see that is that actually some
years ago Aurora Barack installer found
a sub exponential time algorithm for the
problem okay so given any epsilon you
can solve this in times in time
exponential and to the other epsilon
right so of course you know it's not
really efficient but it's not like such
like which appears to be this
exponential or bounds all right so this
is one poll they are the problem okay
maybe we just mentioned that sorry for
introduce so many problems the end I
just want to show what you know what
what is this implications so this is a
problem in graph theory which is very
tightly connected to unique games okay
so we believe they're equivalent but
there's some cabbage so this is the
problem of telling given a graph right
so we have a graph and have two
parameters we understand whether for
always small subset of vertices of the
graph they expand really well or the
words leave them or if all the words to
stay inside them they expend really pool
so the congestions say that it's NP hard
to tell whether for a graph with vertex
set V and edge set e the expansion this
is the definition of expansions use the
probability that our edge from M leaves
em well the expansion of always small
sets is more than epsilon as most set
just MENA region of size like subvolume
okay so it's more constant Delta times
the total volume so we care about small
regions and we want to know whether
there is this one region which is really
no expanding right everything stays
inside re for all in small regions they
are almost completely expanding everyone
everyone lives right all the edges
leaves them like almost all of them
and this is the small set expansion
conjecture okay against contacts to be
np-hard now why I tell you all this
problems well because we have this
equivalence or like approximate
equivalents in some cases okay all these
problems they appear to be like the same
complexion okay so there are a lot of
like carrots here and technicalities
that I'm glossing over so this the in
what direction is known to be true in
the other direction it's conjecture to
be true this is just this what I
mentioned the end right again there's
some cavities in the conversion of
arrows but that's roughly true and this
is what what we prove in this paper
right that's connecting 8 sep 22 24 that
I just show you and two to four three
small set expansion ok so now given
these connections and given the we know
we have some new results about like
algorithms for this guy and that I
mention also hardness for this guy we
can try to convert them right and this
is what we did like that's the last
slide let me just mention the results so
this all we could prove using you know
using these quantum ideas for us a
hierarchy this is what they gives for
what it is for two to four Non for
example given a matrix n by n we can
compute in this number of rounds of sum
of squares so logarithmic in the side of
the matrix additive approximation to the
two to four norm ok when the arrow is
this one so this is a natural error
because you can always prove that the
truth for norm is smaller than this
error okay so you just show that there
is this natural upper bound and you show
that you can have this kind of additive
approximation so it's not clear if this
is good for anything right so but
actually through school lives all over
30 for us lose large oh it's also my
stool but it is it you'll be like yeah
no sorry is a mistake in the type my
type yeah but you're right so it's
better well yeah but you know it all for
this very close to it because the
running time will be n to the order and
over epsilon square right which is
exactly what we saw before rice rice so
2 to the log square n
so just right so you see why we these
were the kind of bounds that we head for
the quantum problem right so if we
convert to this problem we get this this
just comes from the normalization of
like one way locc measurements person
I'm skipping the details now if you
apply this actually a similar bound for
2 to P norms you can record this sub
exponential time algorithm that I make
sure before okay which is the state of
the art for his most set expansion so so
we don't have new algorithm results
using the quantum ideas but at least we
can recover the best thing that people
know classically which is a sub
explanation time algorithm for a small
set expression it just gives an
alternative analysis for for their work
now it also leads to new open problems
okay which I feel an interesting so if
we could improve this quantum analysis
several ways this would lead to new
classical algorithms and I think that
something interesting so for example if
I improvement in the bounce right so I
show this definitive ball it was an
additive error if you could have a
multiplicative error then you could
solve small set expansion quasi
polynomial time okay so and this would
be strong evidence against unique games
right so they could not be np-hard with
this running type unless something very
weird happens we can all see that's
right but will also give better
approximation algorithms for CMS no
because that's the same thing about
unique games contraction if it's true we
understand everything if it's not true
then all this equivalence know where
their loss so you have to work Gabe case
by case so that's right here so there
are you know they're also quantum
arguments for hardness results if we
could improve on those we would also get
this kind of lower bound for our unique
games right which seems to match so you
know so improvement okay safi direct
donation so now the point is that you
know this improvement can be cast this
open problems in quality information
fury by that we don't understand yet
Sandra lights understand so so it no one
possible strategy for trying to solve
unique games contraction is just too
long
or about quantum information theory
right so so there's this new breach and
I think it's worth exploring more and
see what we can get in terms for this
classical algorithms considering this
this new quantum view that we have so
that's also what i told you is just that
this i hope the message was this SOS is
is a very useful I with me 24 problems
in quantum information I give you just
one application that many more in
quantum information itself and in i
sholy popsicle how we can get this quazy
polynomial algorithm for deciding
entanglements from this hierarchy what
was unexpected to us and i think it's a
nice bonus is that conversely quantum
information theory is also useful
theoretical to to understand the
performance of the Sierra key right so
gives new insights into Sierra key and I
show you like some connections 2224 norm
is most set expansion with cuando sepa
ability and use this new connection this
gives potentially a new approach to
resolve this unique games connection
right so of course it's a very hard
conjecture I don't think we were we are
close to solve it to you there's a lot
of barriers that might be very very hard
but i think is something new to think
about which which is interesting so
that's all thanks
so in some sense chores algorithm
entangles everything all right and
achieves a very nice speed up as a
result of that this seems like this
suggested if you had more fancier ways
of generating entangled states then you
might be able to achieve exponential
speed-up if this if you give this some
squares approach lets you get at them
get up for these competitions I mean um
Amanda composition of the several state
yeah well the approximation of several
states yeah but i guess i guess a
different regime here so so here really
we care about complexity in terms of
dimension of the states right sure of
course if you have like an N cubed
system did I mention is already
explanation the number of particles
right so and this complex there is
nothing we can do about right so I think
this is one level below it right please
really like even for very small quantum
states already is very hard to decide
separability for them there is the
exponential growth of the dimension with
a number of particles but even if the
number of particles is is fight smoke
these already becomes a hot rod right so
yeah I'm just thinking about for example
quantum Monte Carlo yeah let's suppose I
have I want to I want to speed up the
rate of which i can compute yes let's
say the occupancy of the state's after a
simulation if I can use in table but to
make up for randomizations in the Mount
Carmel process so I I entangle things in
such a way that I superimpose the things
that need to be superposed the things
that really are additive right not the
things that aren't then I might be able
to design an algorithm which would use
entanglement more surgically over those
all those paths haha if you know what
I'm saying yeah well I guess yeah yeah
okay so so as it I mean yeah I'm just
the problem is how do you do that or how
do you how do you describe the the the
entanglement one right that will result
in the right answer so this is this is
interesting for that point it's icy
right i mean you are going to get
anything that's exponentially good
unless you entangle i think i don't know
how all you're going to do it just yeah
then yeah for some problems yes if you
don't have a very intimate see one
provides natural matter example today
have very small announcement angled it
and Perry exponential speed-up right
that's true he's a lot of course it
gives how you count is a thing yes I'm
good quantify it sits nestled right what
I'm saying is something it allowing her
than that and that is that there's noted
table that it's hard to get an
exponential speed-up that's all not
small amount but I mean you might not
need much as long as there's no
entanglement aren't you classical summit
there's no entanglement Arjun classic
yeah my definition yeah but he's too but
it's actually open problems so suppose
you have a quantum computation for which
your promise that but for me with Mick
states right we mix it with peers late
okay we're states there is to you but
these days it's without a whole simulate
you have this problem always have
several states fully several states with
all the way your loop stitch okay of
similes here yeah you have equivalents
within five problems yeah so it looks
like there is a niche I don't know how
natural a complexity class people try to
develop production yeah right so you
know because this unique games is this
important problem people for about that
mm-hmm but I was there was a little soul
of currently yeah so you know this and
that was the reason for it reduce this
problem small static smashing these are
problem they believe it's really
reducible to the x11 way is it is proved
the other ways conjecture there is
strong evidence but it there is no proof
now you need games we know that if if
you need game is our heart a lot of
other problems are hard as well that's
why it's a very useful one it so that is
there is like to prove any game sadness
yeah right yeah indicates the class that
will literally be huge in so that's
right but in all directionally that's
the prob white so let people have tried
to work out for example max cuts they
really try to prove the max that was
equivalent to unique games but it is
they couldn't do it so it's more like
yet we know a lot of problems which are
unique games hot which are not not to be
np-hard but we don't know if they're
equivalent tilde games right but let's
look for
yeah if you could be other color before
you can do because it is proved it
simply has not know this is the show yep
and you'll be it yet so super question
if all these optimization problems are
equivalent to some question about with
our quantum statistical or not is there
any hope for maybe some farm algorithm
that at least us like low levels of the
law Sarah hierarchy faster or something
like that yeah I thought about it but it
will be nice here but I yeah
maybe yeah but i don't i don't know i
love me how you could search for this
metric extension my bottom always right
but it's yeah i guess because it it
seems to be intermediate complex there
is some hope that right here you can
lose something it hello it's a good
question but I and I've never for about
it
you mention equality called the
injective norm of Y a tensor yes can you
explain what that is is it related to
the rank of a sweet answer or so uh it's
something different from the ring here
ow well it's really just a just a
generalization of a similar age right so
it's kind of like to do a singular value
the tensor exactly yeah right because if
you just have to then it's exactly
single bed right so but now you have
more instances so you cuz but now you
want such a metric your protection like
single man may I don't like to know if
that has any implication of the most
famous three tens or their days write
the matrix multiplication all three
tensor does it say anything about TM
sorry but this is connect to the taste
of rank right this makes multiplication
rest which is unknown it right that's
right that's funny so so I there might
be and i don't i'm not aware but I this
is not the same I stencil right but i
don't i don't know if there's relations
and that could be here originally they
were improvements on that rank like over
coppersmiths you know right off but
right I'm the trip they followed
optimization approaches at all if you
use Cooper Smith our aft brought down
the exponent a little bit that's right
he very recently right likes like right
but this was by this Virginia Williams
overhead and someone here but yeah I
don't know what they believe is
any other questions no way I would say
hey